what's going on
um i just want to say that i i really
appreciate the content that you put out
and um
i'm also very new um but basically i
just wanted to ask you um because i'm 24
and um
i've noticed um
well it's not noticed but i've been
getting you know girls talking to me and
stuff but i know that i'm not in a
position right now to
be
seeking something like that right now as
a young man
and um
also since i was young i struggled what
do you mean by seeking something like
that um like you're 24 like what are you
seeking
well whatever
friends with benefits a wife
girlfriend
why are you seeking a girlfriend at 24
well
what i'm trying to say is that
i i know
i i that's not the position i'm in to be
seeking a girlfriend right now at my age
like you you've been saying
so
my question i guess
um because i i would like to start a
business one day and i know that's where
i should be putting my focus in
but
i i work out a lot and it helps me but
what are some things that you would
recommend me doing to help me keep my
mind
off
of those those things that every guy
thinks about you know getting with girls
and
you know things like that
okay so why do you need to keep your
mind off
getting with girls like why can't you
date girls
well i think i i could if i wanted to
but i think something tells something
for me personally feels like
um
that i shouldn't
why
um
well
well i still haven't moved out yet i
need to
get my own spot and i still need to
get a business of my own started
why do you need to get a business
starter what do you do for a living
right now
um i'm a as a pool technician service i
take care of pools
maintain them where do you live down in
the south
i live in the bay area
okay
um
so dude like here's the thing right i
mean like you're talking about women but
you don't have a lot of like
you're not calibrated to them if you
know what i'm saying right i mean the
sorts of questions that you're asking me
indicate that you don't have a lot of
experience you're probably a little bit
apprehensive maybe some anxiety around
it sort of thing
but i mean if you're going to be dealing
with women if you're attracted to women
and you want to be with them like you've
got to figure it out it's like you know
if you've got some anxiety or some
awkwardness around dealing with
elevators you just have to start riding
elevators in a you know constructive way
that makes you feel comfortable sort of
thing
so
what i'm saying is i mean you don't need
to have a business you don't need to
have
whatever you know to deal with women i
mean does it help yeah absolutely
of course it's going to help i mean if
you're financially successful
women will start to select you more
often than not right but i mean
how many like how many women have you
been with like you know have you dated
women like what's your experience been
yeah i mean i haven't been putting
myself out there i guess you know in in
high school i had this relationship that
lasted outside of high school that i
wanted i thought i wanted to take
seriously but i realized i was in no
position to do that at my age
um
and then on top of that another thing i
wanted to tell you that
is kind of tough but um to say but i
struggled even now since i was
young you know like most guys is
falling into that trap of pornography
and um
how do you
sorry
how do you get away from the porn
yeah and um because that's another thing
that definitely obvious obviously takes
away self-confidence when you're talking
to to women
so
so what you're talking about is
self-control
right
because all you have to do is not go to
the porn website
yeah right
and self-control like
there was pornography around when i was
a kid we didn't have any no fap
movements we didn't have any of that
stuff
right
that was a different time though i mean
uh
guys today are a lot softer than what
they were
yeah 20 20 30 years ago if you know what
i'm saying
um what's your situation at home you
live with your mom and dad
yeah i do um
it's it's
i
i want to move out too and it's it's
also tough in the bay area we're
thinking about trying to find some spots
in texas um
but like i was saying i know i'm not in
a position right now so i was yeah
basically asking you what would you do
if you were me to stay focused on on
on just
improving myself i guess got a comment
here from a fella named nick that says i
think he's using pursuing excellence as
a way to defer from
dealing with the fact that he struggles
socially
right
what do you do for fun
um well when you said struggle socially
i
i have a lot of association
and
i do enjoy socializing that's something
that
is my main way of
of
enjoying myself how like what do you do
to socialize like you play sports is
there group events
yeah online
yeah i mean the group events i do is um
jujitsu and
calisthenic workouts with a group of
guys
we try to improve each other
so why don't you have confidence in
yourself i mean if you're able to get up
and throw your body weight around
and roll and do jiu jitsu or do
calisthenics i mean
you know you don't look scrawny to me it
looks like you've been doing that for a
little bit now so
why are you stuck on you know going
going further with that and having some
serious you know success in life like
some wins
do you like to win
yeah i think that's the main thing that
keeps me keeps me going is is trying to
stay active in those sort of communities
i guess you could say and um
do you like to win them
yeah i i i do like to win but have you
ever competed in like a jiu jitsu uh
competition
not yet i was i'm pretty fresh i would
the only things i competed in was soccer
and how'd you do there
i did pretty well um i would get very
competitive i would
i would um
i would get to the point where you know
if things weren't going my way
it would get to a competitive point
where you know
sometimes you would throw hands or you
know some stuff like that
yeah well
i think that if you get into some
competitions you know and and start to
feel some wins and
like the strength and the confidence
that comes with that it just happens by
osmosis right i mean
if you put yourself on a dating app
right now and you got a match and you
started doing some messaging back and
forth and you met in person it probably
wouldn't go very far because i mean you
got an awkwardness around you which is
totally fine because everybody's like
that at some point right it's just like
you got to like kind of end that awkward
party right i did some awkward ass [ __ ]
when i was young too i mean like i'll
tell you right now you know if you want
to hear a stupid story i remember i was
like 19 or 20 and i had a date with this
girl and i read somewhere in some
[ __ ] magazine that you know you have
to bring a certain colored flower when
you meet them and then another certain
colored flower after you know at the end
of the day to close it
and
you know like a [ __ ] i basically went
out and followed exactly what the stupid
ad said in the magazine i don't even
know what it was it wasn't a men's
magazine it wasn't like
power lifting usa or anything like that
was probably some stupid [ __ ] that i
found lying around at the uh office or
uh something like that and uh yeah that
that felt really dumb you know if i'm
being honest like as i kind of reflect
back on it and i tell the story it's
it's practically embarrassing but we all
like come from an embarrassing awkward
position when you start dealing you know
as a young guy it's just you have to get
over it right yeah and sometimes it
takes you know the realization that okay
well you know fapping 15 times a day is
a really bad use of my time or you know
not being able to
strike up you know comfortable
conversation with a random stranger uh
is a skill that i want to sort of
develop you just kind of lean into it
man you just lean into these things you
just start doing it um you know men must
become
right you have to make something out of
yourself if you're a chick all you had
to do is look pretty
yeah
you could have the dullest personality
if you're pretty and pleasant and you
have you know some basic culinary skills
you're set
a guy
you have to make something out of
yourself man like
okay pool boy
okay that's a start are you the hot chad
pool boy that's like you know banging
chicks while you're doing the pool work
probably not right but you know could
you be maybe but i mean like the whole
pool pool boy thing is just to start
right you got to lean in something
bigger and you're already starting to
think about chasing excellence but the
problem is is that you need to start
executing on it how much time you spend
watching youtube content like what do
you watch right now like this you know
specific channels or anything that you
watch
yeah i watch a lot of of you and i watch
um
i mean i guess just other red pill
content like this guy named darius and
he just talks about you know he spends
he spends too much time just talking
[ __ ] but without providing solutions if
if you're gonna spend time on youtube
who cares about oh look at this
[ __ ] clip on tick tock of this chick
behaving badly and this is uh this is
women blah blah blah sort of thing
get
on the ice and start taking shots at the
net put on your equipment i'm talking
about hockey right now put on your
equipment strap on your skates
and get on the ice and start taking some
shots at net you don't need to consume
as much crap as what you're consuming i
mean if you've watched a bunch of my
videos you have everything that you need
to know
okay and i mean like everything that you
need to know is literally in my book and
on the playlist on
you know dealing with uh stuff for me
okay and like you said get on the ice
and and just
um you know get out there
do you
um do do you recommend that i still do
that even with the struggle that i have
of of watching pornography and
trying to get a hold of that just stop
watching porn dude yeah you know you
feel the need to watch porn go take a
cold shower
get out of the shower you feel the need
to watch porn again take another cold
shower
pretty soon you know you're going to be
tired of taking cold showers or just
start doing push-ups
do like 20 push-ups you know if you feel
the need it's dude self-control is a
little tiny muscle somewhere in your
brain in your nervous system that just
activates and strengthens over time
right
okay
like you're like you're a man you need
to start taking ownership for your life
and being accountable for where for
where you're going and if you can't deal
with something as basic as not fapping
yeah deal with that first dude
get yourself busy get a uh you know get
another hobby like add like add
something else to the roster do you like
motorcycles
that's something that i want to get into
next dude get a bike you're in
california [ __ ] wicked roads out
there
rip up to mount tam man i've i've ridden
all those roads they're beautiful
get a motorcycle you know you're a young
man you can buy something for a couple
thousand dollars they're not expensive
yeah
right good guys good guys ride bikes man
you start hanging out do they still have
alice's restaurant out in the forest i
think it was called alice's right
oh yeah um
i actually i'm not too sure if it's
still around i should uh look that up
yeah
like you know keep yourself busy i mean
the only time that you're going to find
yourself in a position where you're
wasting time doing dumb [ __ ] is if you
got nothing else going on so fill that
nothing else going on with something
going on yeah
all right
thank you all right man take care
you